bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france art en
confinement nationale de trois semaines
comment les israéliens ont-ils accueilli
cette annonce
bonjour écoutez je pense que comme tout
le monde
face à ce genre de décision la réaction
des pas excessivement donne on va se
retrouver à nouveau pendant trois
semaines pratiquement bloqué avec une
petite différence malgré tout par
rapport au premier confinement c'est que
premier confinement qui avait lieu au
moment de la première vague est juste
aux alentours des fêtes de pâques n'a
d'abord du rec très peu de temps 3 4
jours et doit d autre part c'était
vraiment un compliment extrêmement
sévère s'est brisé à l'aéroport était
fermé
on pouvait pas partir en dehors de chez
soi plus de 100 mètres et c'est là cette
fois ci le compliment est un tout petit
peu mais vraiment très légèrement plus
souple puisque on va quand même
continuer à pouvoir s'écrire livrée par
les restaurants ce qui n'était pas le
cas la première fois et l'aéroport ben
gourion est ouvert ce qui permet quand
même certaines personnes de pouvoir
partir dans l'étrange est donc lié à la
fois du bon et du mauvais
personnellement je ne pense pas que le
confinement durera que trois semaines
temps monsieur natanyahou annonce que
peut-être plus à mon avis est déjà prévu
que le confinement dire plus
on est arrivé quand même à des points de
4000 nouveaux cas par jour ce qui est
élevé par rapport aux pays comme israël
dans près de 40 villes il ya aussi un
couvre-feu déjà mises en place à ce que
c'est suffisant est ce que les
israéliens on respecte bien ce
couvre-feu alors la particularité que
les israéliens partage avec les français
s'y est quand même un manque de
discipline assez fréquent est assez
répandu sur l'a10 faut quand même
préciser une chose c'est que l'épidémie
s'est surtout développée dans la
communauté arabe et dans la communauté
des juifs ultrareligieux donc le fait
que le confinement soit mis en place aux
alentours des fêtes n'est pas tout à
fait par hasard parce que
malheureusement on est dans un pays
où le religieux très très important même
les gens en laïc comme moi ont tendance
quant à respecter les traditions les
fêtes etc
et cette période est quand même la plus
importante dans le cas lors des juifs là
pendant trois semaines il va y avoir la
foi le nouvel an ensuite
le jour du grand pardon et comme vous le
savez le jour le plus important pour les
juifs et derrière son pote qui va durer
une semaine donc céline père devant
laquelle les gens se déplacent pour les
uns sur les autres se réunissent en
famille et c'est là que les tv
l'épidémie a le plus de chances de se
propager par ailleurs effectivement on a
on a mis un couvre feu
une quarantaine de villes qui sont
classées rouge ce sont des villes ultra
religieuses et des villes arabes
donc plutôt que arrivé à cette situation
alors que malgré tout l'épidémie s'est
de nouveau répondu depuis depuis
maintenant près de deux mois
je pense que le gouvernement aurait pu
prendre des mesures beaucoup plus propre
mais il y avait une espèce d'optimisme
les israël était le pays qui a le mieux
au monde gérait la première crise qui a
été considéré comme le plus sûr par
rapport au corona donc a eu une espèce
de cocorico nationale d israël sont lime
aphatie ce qu'on a sig a géré la
première crise
maintenant on retourne à la vie normale
et du jour l'ambiance retrouvée
pratiquement d'un confinement un retour
à la vie normale avec les conséquences
que l'on voit qu'ils ont subi
aujourd'hui nous parler des fêtes
religieuses est aussi un contexte
particulier parce qu'il ya de nombreux
rassemblements notamment pour demander
la démission du premier ministre
benyamin nétanyahou
ces mesures de restrictions seront
confinement est ce que vous pensez que
certains peuvent percevoir ces mesures
comme justement une décision pour
ralentir la contestation ou bien c'est
véritablement en effet faire face à
l'urgence sanitaire
je pense quelle nécessité face à
l'urgence sanitaire les les
les chiffres des chiffres sont là à
partir du moment où dans un pays comme
israël on se retrouve à avoir quatre
mille nouveaux cas par jour et on a
dépassé les mille morts
on est à 1123 mort je prends aujourd'hui
c'est quand même terrible quand on sait
que la première crise c'est bien
avec moins de 300 morts j'espère te dire
une bêtise mais en tout cas c'est dans
ces autres dans ces chiffres là alors il
faut savoir prendre que deux communautés
en israël la communauté arabe et la
communauté ultra originaux ce qui
représente 22% de la communauté
nationale représentent à eux deux l 2
53% et de décontaminer c'est ça les
chiffres importants et c'est là que le
gouvernement aurait dû connaissant leurs
habitudes intervenir beaucoup plus tôt
parce que là on a beau avoir eu des
mesures post confinant qui consistait à
prévenir les gens de ne pas se réunira à
plus de temps en temps personne à porter
des masques à rester en distance les uns
par rapport aux autres ce sont des
mesures qui n'ont pas été respectées
essentiellement dans ces milieux là et
on a vu dans des villes arabes des
mariages de 200 300 personnes et
également des réunions à plus de 100
personnes dans les milieux juifs
religieux
maintenant les manifestations assez
curieusement les manifestants respecte
un peu plus les mesures prises par le
gouvernement ne serait ce que j'ai
l'impression que pour avoir le droit de
continuer à à manifester pour le départ
de bibi netanyahu
et dans ces communes dans la communauté
c'est qu'on communauté mais parmi les
gens qui qui manifestent on n'a pas
retrouvé on n'a pas trouvé une
recrudescence de l'épidémie
alors est ce que ces chiffres là sont
des vrais chiffres où est-ce qu'ils
servent à modérer pondérer je ne sais
pas aujourd'hui
en tout cas la réalité c'est que la des
communautés où l'épidémie se répand plus
vite et par milliers de manifestants ce
n'est pas vraiment le cas merci beaucoup
hier arrière je rappelle que vous êtes
reporter écrivain réalisateur de
documentaires